[Applaudissements]
des combats de boue là les deux l'art
les deux hommes les deux savoie vous
êtes prêtre oui en tout cas bravo pour
vos pieds d211 gp dj à beinheim à elle à
dépliant du raid et on dirait des petits
bouts de pain dieu bénisse
merci c'est moi en tout cas vous a fait
une très belle manucure alors les séries
c'est très simple pédicure pédicure oui
parce que non parce que vous avez des
mains et des pierres et des barres
benhaim vous allez devoir défendre
quelque chose oui je vous explique pia
estelle denis qui va devoir venir
prendre sa soupe derrière vous ah ils
allaient tout faire donc pour l'en
empêcher
la coque et le combat debout c'est
derrière c'est la petite piscine qui est
derrière
ouais ouais là on a beaucoup de moi
demain
[Rires]
ah ouais merci lourd dit le producteur
bravo et bravo nourdine bravo jamais dit
de regarder ce qu'on avait fait la
dernière fois c'est vrai que c'était
exceptionnel là ils nous ont bien un
truc comme et c'est une honte sans
rigoler alors allez-y rentrer dans la
boue les chéris rentrer dans la boue
merci merci c'est qui ça à voile à
valérie bénaïm elle se prend au jeu elle
se prend vraiment pour eux ah oui mais
dites moi il ya un centimètre de
rassurer à oui mais vous avez vous
n'avez pas vous faire mal léché reading
en fait si j'étais alors vous savez quoi
j'annule la séquence j'annule la
séquence atmosphère mal et essaye de
témoins ça a été mal préparé ça a été
mal préparé j'ai peur pour elle voilà je
vous le dis j'ai peur pour vous non je
déconne et à la vie
à grand chose ne vous fait pas mal
j'espère quatre mois ce soir là j'ai
peur à voir
[Applaudissements]
les recours collectifs
[Musique]
à voir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
voilà merci
bon c'est ça que vous voulez c'est la
soupe voilà comme ça c'est réglé a l'air
veut le plateau merci égérie voilà comme
ça ça c'est fait merci merci mes chéris
merci
et ben voilà c'est pas compliqué